hey everyone I am here today with Katie
who you may recognize from the now
infamous double slit reaction video that
I made Payton you know I thought we'd
have a bit of a discussion today about
what science means to us and the way
we're doing this is by typing in a
phrase into Google we've got a laptop
here the phrase you've chosen is what
does science and there's a few results
here we're just going to run through
them use it as a way to discuss I guess
what science is and what it means to us
exactly yeah so let's get into it so the
first question is what does science mean
oh it's the first result like thumbs up
what the science mean so yeah I guess
these are questions you hear every day
but I think there's something like a
monotonous a scientist what the science
mean I guess the definition for me or
science is something that uses the
scientific method like that means making
a hypothesis of something like an S or
an educated guess on how something is
going to work and then testing that
hypothesis maybe doing experiments
getting back to that either supports the
hypothesis or helps you create a new one
and sort of iterating through that
method and that doesn't just apply to
like something you would do in a lab
with like chemicals in a lab coat it's
just an approach to the world like
scientifically looking at things making
assumptions or hypotheses on how they
work and seeing if the evidence supports
that and if it does great and if it
doesn't change in your mind to me I'm
from a non physics degree non science
degree I'm very much in the arts side I
think science is just life in general
so I think everything is science and
it's like you look at something yeah
that's that science because if it
weren't for that we wouldn't have or we
wouldn't know as much as we get it out
and he's just amazing really
and even like I know it's not
necessarily what it just means to me but
science is life yeah I guess that's why
I'm interested
your perspective on these things from
someone who maybe as more on the arts
side of science I think that's still a
legitimate view of science and to hear
that people see science as life like
that's it's good to know and to see how
it's thought of you know among the
yellow because I know on my channel I
used to have a very niche audience of
like mostly I was watched by other
scientists and they would have a similar
definition to me of what science was but
now I guess my reach is growing a bit
and I want to make sure I'm including
people and knowing what they think of
science and yeah what it means to him
yeah and I feel like I've learnt so much
from internal like I don't know like
that was look experiment that's one
thing but even just by watching all of
your videos I was saying to Toby before
that one of my favorite videos is the
Rapunzel hair one because I'm going to
present into like Disney sort of stuff
and so the fact that you are able to
then bring it something that's maybe not
technically what people think of yes
science I mean like hey it is yeah and
here's how it is incorporated and here's
get in a real life situation yeah that's
good to hear alright so next one on our
little list here so what the science
stand for not sure I quite understand
what that me my decides an acronym I
think I know what it means
yes it's an acronym it means let me
follow the letters science can
independently educate nice children
everywhere I like it because it has
science
that's why like the best definitions are
the ones that say the word in the
definition yeah I think we nailed that
one I think that stands for maybe they
can let us know in the comments yeah
what does why is science stand for what
is what other acronyms do you have that
mm I'm looking forward to some acrostic
poem yeah right what does science
fiction mean I mean it's another sort of
weird question what a science fiction
mean well to me science fiction I think
of in terms of like popular books and
movies and stuff where it's something
that's kind of science II but the
science doesn't quite exist yet so like
really fast spaceship Star Wars Star
Wars like things you could imagine being
done with science but we currently can't
do one that aren't like widely available
something yes yeah I agree and I think
whenever I think of science fiction I
think of Blade Runner because I did that
at school yeah and so now all of my
perception of played by is like oh sorry
old my perception of science fiction is
played but I'm like well one day it's
gonna die like that and that's just
science yeah I think my favorite science
fiction movie is an arrival yes Okin
about that in a video before I just love
the concept yeah I think that's me with
interstellar yeah I'm gonna say every
time I watch it I'm like well yeah my
mind is gone so I hear people talking
about science fiction
maybe being important to science in
terms of like it inspires science so
like if the movie comes out in the
direct us whatever it has a vision for
some new technology and how it's going
to change our life and give us a new way
of living science tends to work towards
those things yes that is technical
animation so in a way it is like the
apex of science like yeah it can be what
inspires the technology to catch up yeah
definitely
everything about science fiction movies
that I made a few decades ago is when
they have like these amazing things and
like it's gonna happen by 2000 and then
be like oh yeah but they've got dreams
and we all need them yeah and I think it
still helps to drive the inspiring stuff
yes yeah absolutely
all right here's a big one what does
science mean to you I think we might
have slightly different views on this
for me what asides mean to me it's
science really does I guess define my
life in a way because you know I would
consider myself a scientist I've done a
lot of years in university and school
learning science and basing my career
around science and even this YouTube
channel I hope it's based around talking
about science and my life studying
science so it in a way it can be hard
for me to separate science from my
identity yeah it's like that is you yeah
they're very woven together and I guess
I chose that because I was very
interested in science but science to me
isn't just a topic you choose to study
like at school it's almost like a
religion like yes yeah beliefs a
philosophy on looking at the world
through these I guess scientific lenses
and I guess I feel a lot of people turn
to religion to find a place of belonging
and to find an explanation like to find
answers cuz everyone wonders like what
are we what is life you know there
really yes all those are things that I
know the question is gonna be answering
and to me I gained a satisfaction to
those answering those questions from
science yeah
and that was so much better than my
answer is ever going to be that was
amazing
which is why you do Sciences like you
can tell how much of a passion that you
have for it which is so great
mm-hmm I think for me science again when
I say a scientist like science is
everywhere and so to me it's like
technology it's growing and learning and
I actually work at a science and arts
museum so I'm able to bring that every
day into what I do and we get to teach
kids that from like five to fifteen and
give them new opportunities that they
might not get because of science and
watching them discover things especially
like with technology and with coding and
even that side of science you can see
them little minds yeah and it's just
such a beautiful little thing to just
get more people learning and learning
and that in this is just rambling but
that like encouragement to learn and to
continue learning I think is what
science is and what it brings out in you
a little bit yes and also science is
looking up at the sky and having a head
explode because the universe is amazing
so I really like that answer I just from
talking to you I get the sense that to
use science means a way of inspiring
people yeah a way of improving their
lives I think they look at the one yeah
yes so I think in a way we're saying the
same thing yours is just definitely more
eloquent so cats our last question on
there and I hope you got something out
of our discussion I really like talking
about science and the philosophy of
science it's just something I really
like to do and talking broadly to my
friends about it that's one of my
favorite things so thank you guys for
watching go over and subscribe to
Katie's channel I'll put a link in the
description and we're going to film a
nother video for her channel also using
some google themed games a google feud
yes so we're going to play a game called
google feud you'll know a little bit
more about it if you head over to my
channel so pretty much you can pick a
little category and Google will ask you
a question or start a question for you
for example why does sport or what does
sport and then you have a few changes
you have to get if you have three
chances pretty much to get 10 of those
answers it's gonna be like I don't know
it's not sports so that's I don't know
like why is sport the worst thing that's
gonna go my yeah all right thank you
guys